Republican Arizona Senator John McCain
is continuing his feud against stupidity
yesterday I played this clip for you of
John McCain slamming Donald Trump for
his bone spurs draft-dodging refer
deferments in a recent c-span interview
I have another clip from John McCain for
you and this time he is destroying a Fox
News reporter remember when in school we
were told I was told anyway there are no
stupid questions I've never agreed with
that I've always thought yeah there are
actually stupid questions and apparently
John McCain believes that there are he
was approached by Peter Doocy
whose idiocy is often only eclipsed by
his father on the same Network Fox News
Steve Doocy Peter Doocy
asked McCain about his relationship with
Donald Trump if you're watching watch
the expression of confusion and disgust
on John McCain's face as he is asked a
really dumb question by Peter Doocy here
and in fact Senator McCain I mean I want
you to listen to how he responded to one
of our reporters questions as your
relationship with the president frayed
to the point that you are not going to
support anything that he comes to you
and asks would you say something that
stupid why would you ask something that
done huh my job as United States Senator
is the son of the from Arizona which I
was just re-elected to you mean that I
am somehow one to behave in a way that
I'm gonna block everything because of
some personal disagreement it's a dumb
question
there are many criticisms of John McCain
but the suggestion that he would block
all of trumps bills because he's not
getting along with Trump is ridiculous
he would of course only do that to Obama
because of political disagreements not
personal I think I I am sort of kidding
John McCain did get in the way of a lot
of President Obama's legislation but I
do believe although I disagree with John
McCain on politics that it was because
of political disagreements not because
of personal disagreements with President
Obama that he did that and the truly
disturbing thing here is the assumption
that Republicans in Congress should just
fall in line and go along with whatever
Trump proposes right why is that the
default position that were it not for
personal disagreements
john mccain and all republican senators
would just be rubber stamping every
single thing that Donald Trump does
shouldn't McCain's loyalty be to his
constituents and not to Donald Trump
anyway and what's very funny is that
McCain used to be the loved maverick on
Fox News right he told it like it is
wasn't going to be intimidated and now
all of a sudden that John McCain is
finding the questions from Fox News dumb
and stupid McCain is the crazy old guy
yelling get off my lawn which I have
previously characterized John McCain as
full disclosure but that was not the way
that Fox News used to characterize him
until all of a sudden he doesn't find
their questions relevant now I do think
that this is unfair to Peter Doocy a
little bit we should probably be blaming
Steve Doocy
for this because the Apple usually
doesn't fall that far from the tree and
it's probably Steve Ducey's role model
ship of Peter Doocy that is more
responsible for this than anything we
would blame Peter for directly but
pathetic I mean just embarrassing and
great thing that John McCain called him
out the video you just watched was made
possible by support from you please go
to patreon.com slash david pakman show
you can make a pledge of as little as $1
per month and every dollar helps to
support the work that we're doing
particularly in light of the YouTube ad
boycott which has been really bad